[Musik]
wir sind hier in mir fällt mir fällt in
walldorf gestern um 18 uhr fegte ein
tornado über unser grundstück und
entwurzelte einen baum ging im
hintergrund sichtbar zirka 30 meter hoch
er fiel auf mein auto kaputt und
verstörte ist wirklich komplett zurzeit
sind wir bei 150 einsätzen im gesamten
stadtgebiet von mörfelden-walldorf
ich wäre der einzelnen so war das die
stadt erst einmal komplett von der
außenwelt abgeschnitten waren alle
zufahrts bundesstraßen mit bäumen
übersät waren
weiterhin wurde im ortszentrum von
felten bei einem viergeschossigen büro
und geschäftshaus und
es wurde das komplette dach 250
quadratmeter abgerissen und auf den
davor befindlichen parkplatz
geschleudert wo auch mehrere autos
darunter begraben wurden aber zum glück
keiner verletzt wurde